في مدينه طرابلس شماليه لبنان خرج مئات
المتظاهرين الرافضين للعدوان الاسرائيلي
على غزه ورفع المتظاهرون الاعلام
الفلسطينيه ولافتات تؤكد دعمهم لشعب غزه
وللمقاومة
صمه برلين ومدينه دورف مظاهرات للتنديد
بالحرب الاسرائيليه على القطاع والمجازر
البشعه التي ترتكب بحق الشعب الفلسطيني
وتطالب بوقف
الحرب وخرجت في مدينه اندهوفن الهولنديه
مظاهرات مندده ايضا بالعدوان الاسرائيلي
وردد المتظاهرون هتفات تنادي بالحريه
لفلسطين وتندد بالهجمات الاسرائيليه وقتل
الاطفال والمدنيين العس
تظهر ايضا عدد من ابناء الجاليه العربيه
والنرويجي امام السفاره المصريه في
العاصمه النرويجيه اوسلو تضامنا مع القطاع
وطلب المتظاهرون السلطات المصريه بفتح
معبر رفح بشكل كامل ودائم لادخال
المساعدات ووقف
الح اما في مدينه مالمو السويديه فخرجت
مظاهره تندد بالحرب الاسرائيليه المستمره
ورفضا للمجازر المرتكبه بحق الفلسطينيين
وطالب المحتجون بوقف اطلاق النار
[موسيقى]
في